qu'est ce qui a changé et et pmp pour
vous dans votre vie de tous les jours
tout alors nommé beinheim vous étiez
connu avant dont carey queen un messie
mais non mais franchement ça a changé
énormément ce que moi les gens qui me
suivaient avait avait mon âge
maintenant il ya aussi des deals qui me
suivent et qui sont hyper s'empare d'un
jour qui vous suivent le voc roche donc
apparemment l'attention attentivement
mois ils vont pas assez vite fait non
mais d'accord oui mais voilà donc j'ai
ça m'a donné une bouffée d'air frais
bush julien combes et sarir should we
kill stars
vous plaisantez alors on va prendre de
l'essence il est avec vous cyril hanouna
et au restaurant il est où cyril hanouna
on va en vacances il va venir si rien
[Applaudissements]
n'assure pas que vous avez vous étiez
sur nrj 12 hd et gangstar d'autres non
mais ce que j'ai amené à l'émission
l'émission je peux vous dire voir will
audio
[Applaudissements]
mon chéri j'ai trouvé une famille j'ai
trouvé l'amour s'est retrouvé le sourire
s'est trouvé la vie à l'asse peut vous
dire vous avez trouvé surtout la
connerie je crois qu'on se trouvait jean
alors celui pour qui ça a pu choquer
tout ça ces caveaux avant tout mon poste
est chopé pas il est toujours au figaro
je me rappelle j'avais fait nintendo
avec une faisait de la peine
il voulait être sur tous les dossiers et
chopper personnes depuis il est sur
aucun dossier toujours pas toujours pas
mais moi je connais son nom michel non
mais c'est vrai qu'avant je veux c'est
beaucoup gêné je pensais beaucoup j'ai
des pommes mais le plus grand changement
[Rires]
et maintenant c'est vrai que j'arrive
beaucoup plus à pécho du coup maintenant
j'avance et quand je tends trouver une
resté sept ans dix ans avec elle en
attend gens trouvent une c'est vrai que
sept minutes faible demande et au dos
bien sûr gilbert dette alors vous vous
sachant les parce que vous allez arriver
vous étiez versol connu mais pas comme
ça surtout avant je faisais des demandes
en mariage en me disais non grasse à
tous pas
n'étant ni de l'année oui bon voilà oui
non ça et non ça change énormément de
choses physiques mon avis personnel sur
fessionnels voilà oui c'est une aventure
extraordinaire
voilà bah oui ça change le quotidien
voilà moi je suis très ancré dans le
quotidien
ça change la vie quotidienne combat sous
région scanner couleur est plus beau
qu'avant le succès rimbaud c'est une
vraie s'il vous plaît il s'est embelli
on va pas quand même si c'est la
meilleure
il avait nourri boss même moi d'abord je
vous approche de plus près et ça
honnêtement ça me fait plaisir parce que
rtl vous voyez de plus loin régional
gère plus de coupables beaucoup plus
jeunes il y en a beaucoup qui cherchent
des grand'mères vous savez pour faire
des ronds fatalement on vient de se
rendre compte c'est un barbecue
[Applaudissements]
je prêche d'euros si c'est vrai que je
voulais pas venir dans cette émission je
pouvais pas en béret quelques-uns qui ça
le plus aux boys avaient enora énorme
agile
j'étais totalement réfractaire et non
plus et en fait
premièrement j'ai ce qui est curieux
c'est que les gens m'ont découvert alors
ça fait quand même quelques années que
faisait la télévision ils m'ont trouvé
sympathique enfin on va dire mais et
surtout c'est vrai que ça j'ai commencé
chez drucker on avait une quotidienne et
c'était un plaisir d'aller bosser parce
que tous les jours on se marrait et ont
bossé et moi j'ai redécouvert après 20
ans un de retrouver le beau boulot tous
les jo avec bonheur avec des gens qu'on
aime et qui sont je vous dis franchement
de vrais gentils honnêtement j'avais des
tonnes d'à priori et je pensais que tout
ça était fake mais tous été fabriqués
parfois on s'engueule c'est vrai mais
j'ai trouvé des gens qui ont vraiment
beaucoup d'amour à donner
et j'ai trouvé un petit frérot que je
pensais pas être exempts voilà un amour
mon chéri va me faire ch cheryl
[Musique]